okay we are recording the World Rally
Championship has become the number one
TV sport in the world we're joined by
lacha team manager chare fio raing is
like a war and I'm the commander of an
army Walter ah it we've got a
competitive car this year yeah very
incredible Car Central engine light car
very special materials four-wheel drive
no no no no no two wheel drive you can't
beat them with a normal
car yes we
can if you drive
it give me one good reason why I should
accept because we are The Underdogs Jo
CH Cher thinks he can challenge us
without a four-wheel drive they SP out
was Ice don't you
think you still think that the Germans
are only technology in an organization
don't you don't believe all the cliche
Fu you welcome to the opening of the
51st Monte Carlo
rally rallying is a dangerous sport does
anything frighten you one thing
losing
[Music]
[Applause]
go now we have the second stage in
TOS let's go but that car will never win
against me the drivers why do they risk
their lives
death is afraid of those who pursue
it to win I'll do whatever I have to do
I'll only do six races take it or
even watch howy play it all out in one
last
stage wter you must recover 10 seconds
it's now never push push
push you okay I'm just thinking about
what
winning